[Music]
the moon is a necessary first step for
exploration of the planets to fly men
there and return them safely in this
decade is the goal of NASA's project
Apollo the early missions of mercury and
the experience from Germany have brought
this country to the next major milestone
the first Apollo 3 manned space flight
these are the men to fly that mission
command pilot virgil grissom Mercury
Gemini and now Apollo his third time
into space one of the original seven
astronauts the senior pilot Edward white
he will be remembered for his space walk
during Germany for White has been
specializing in the computers and
training for the upcoming mission
astronaut Roger Chaffee will man the
third Apollo seat he's been
concentrating on the flight plan and
experiments I think everybody in the
space program has been asked this 50
times and it's probably the toughest
question to answer and not sound shall
we say corny with the answer it's a new
phase of exploration it's you might say
and Samba will try to it's there would
be neglect in our duties as people as
human beings if we didn't try to
investigate it we're improving our
engineering capability we're building
new equipment that has a untold number
of uses and fields that we can't even
conceive of today the scientific aspect
I don't think anybody can predict what
it's going to be
things that will find there some of them
basic geologic things that we might find
there that have long since been
destroyed by weather on earth might give
us more insight into the birth of our
universe of birth of our solar system
you flew on on mercury wheel on jiminy
now you're flying on Apollo there's a
law of averages so far as the
possibility of a catastrophic thing
you'd bother you at all sir
no you sorta have to put that out of
your mind was always a possibility that
you can have a catastrophic failure of
course it's gonna happen on any fighter
gonna have it on them on the last one as
well as the first one so away it just
plan as best you can to take care of all
of these eventualities that you get a
well-trained crew and get go fly
[Music]